on va regarder quoi la torah garder est
un duroc à battre ça se fait pas nous
pour le coup mais c'est quand même les
copains mano negra vont passer le
diplôme 88 30 ans toujours là des
souvenirs avec par exemple parabellum
l'un des groupes phares de la scène rock
des années 80
kiska
qui aurait pensé qu'une bande des niafs
qui opposa résisterez animerait une
prise culturel au coeur de la ville à
l'époque à bourges il n'y avait qu'un
festival de chanson quelques maisons des
jeunes et maison de la culture
très vite il décide de créer mais troque
un monde à part
tout de suite on s'est rendu compte que
c'est pas rigolo et que tout ce qu'on
faisait résonner à la fois
artistiquement ou musicalement ce qu'on
allait voir à paris tout l'émergence du
rock alternatif du punk français de
maritie s'était pas représenté les
assauts c'était plutôt rock'n'roll quoi
c'était plutôt rock'n'roll du genre la
musique s'est arrêtée en 58 oussalah et
donc effectivement on est arrivé sur une
terre vierge
on peut dire
là sa joyeuse merdier au concert
clandestins au groupe d'alternative
signé sous le label indépendant bondage
recode
alors là
la page 2 le pot croquis il est né cet
immobilisme la fin des années soixante
dix mme ouvre vraiment il y avait peu de
contre culture 77 venu en tout cas
compter et il y avait besoin de faire
quelque chose de immédiat urgent et qui
saute à la gueule des gens pour ça que
les groupes qu'on a lancé souvent
c'était pas les bons techniciens ils
sont venus après c'était pas des gens
qui avaient des années expérience juste
avant lui de le faire
il suffisait de voir le faire on faire
puis lisez j'existe donc je suis
dans toute la question du punk toute la
question ensuite de la culture hip hop
tout ça ça passait pas quoi maintenant
si ça passe pas c'est simplement parce
que c'est un produit sur une scène
pendant un festival alors que tout ça
c'est des cultures c'est pas simplement
des produits des concerts voilà c'est
autre chose quoi c'est des manières de
vivre c'est d'une manière s'organiser en
collectif des manières d'être et de
faire des mondes un peu à la manière des
enfants qui posent une couverture sur
deux chaises faire une tante d'indiens
hérel
torités
constellation 84 85 ans berlin est une
ville qui m'a beaucoup dit et dans
quelle dans les années 80 bien entendu
il y avait toutes ces réflexions déjà au
niveau des la réquisition des espaces
des maisons collectibles inflexion sur
le collectif la rébellion aussi sur des
projets ensemble à réflexion sur eux
ce réquisitionner des espaces
industriels et par nous pour en faire
des espaces culturels c'est une vraie
démarche
ça bouillonne et metropcs crée alors le
up du printemps de bourges invités
compagnie théâtrale et offre leur
première scène aux [__] vertes
il a toujours
et là on a eu envie d'amener tous ces
artistes à bouche quoi mais à l'année
c'est à dire que nous tout de suite on
n'était pas dans une politique
festivalière tu respires pas de l'air
une fois par an quoi a besoin et la
culture c'est sa race et d'oxygène
c'est de la manière de se remplir de se
frotter avec le monde avec la
contradiction avec liar pour avancer
quoi pour avancer pour former ton esprit
et puis aller vers d émancipation
partager
aimait trop plein des styles et
quartiers nord de bourges dans les
années 90
c'est la création du festival ziva un
festival entièrement gratuit
on a tiré un constat aussi qu' une
partie des gens que nous côtoyer ici
d'une phrase on avait une connaissance
très relative de leur histoire
artistique et culturelle
pour nous c'est un vrai plaisir
d'habiter ces artistes là et de partager
ces moments aussi de fait et puis de
fierté parce que tu es d'un coup tu as
il devrait être un tout le monde était
fier aussi de rencontrer sa sortie de
passer un moment ensemble parce que
c'est aussi la question du vivre
ensemble quels que soient l'âge c'est à
dire du petit au grand ol a même mis au
pas puis voilà d'être là ensemble et de
passer un bon moment quoi et c'est ça
qui reste en fait c'est la trace qui
reste après dans la mémoire pas étonnant
que le plasticien claude lévêque
gravitent autour de l'endroit depuis des
années avec des oeuvres souvent investis
d'un caractère politique
l'artiste représentait la france à la
biennale de venise il y a cinq ans avec
le grand soir
appartements occupés est le fruit d'une
résidence de deux ans dans un quartier
populaire
la cage aux poules symbolise le cacher
on n'est pas dans une institution de
friche culturelle ça m'ennuie un peu ces
lieux là le soient devenus quand même
pas mal j'ai connu comme ça avec cette
résistance avec calme
une position vraiment politique c'est ce
que par rapport à la situation dans la
ville est tout simple donc ses proches
des gens mais c'est non plus pas facile
tous les jours on oublie que bourges pas
une très grande ville et tout ça mais
c'est un travail qui marquera l'histoire
aussi ne serait-ce que partout les gens
qu'ils ont pu inviter domaines de la
musique de la danse du théâtre mais
aussi de l'art contemporain
on
à l'époque dans les années 90 il y avait
des études sur le berry où il disait que
c'était là la région la plus arriérée de
france on voit là à se dire il arrive un
moment
pourquoi aussi parce que les créateurs
parce que les activistes et tous
préfèrent et à toulouse nantes bordeaux
marseille ou lyon que dans les petits
lieux ou dans les petites villes ou dans
des territoires plus difficiles ici
c'est des terres difficiles pour les
territoires artistiques avec lesquels on
travaille mais ça a du sens parce que
moi c'est une présence affirmée
face au vide
pour eux la liberté c'est d'augmenter
celle des autres
en 1993 et metropcs relais la pétition
d'une dizaine de groupes pour créer
trois studios de répétition quand la
municipalité a récupéré donc le squat
dans lequel on était pour avoir un
projet immobilier nous ont mis ici l'on
dit mais vous affolez pas vous n'allez
pas resté là on sait que c'est pas
convenable donc quand on est arrivé là
je te dis pas on avait les moustaches
qui frisait on s'y met c'est tout à fait
ça qu'on veut alors que la mairie
communiste à l'époque une salle de
concert de chinon alors il en a tous là
ça va mettre longtemps mais on a tous
c'est un soir j'ai été à aimer europe et
il y avait des concerts et il y avait il
y avait plein de jeunes punks à chiens
défoncé et ça m'a vachement inspiré
une bouée
quelle soirée
à l'est
la laisse tomber
collet
ici c'était une usine et metropcs garde
le même esprit collectif
mais comment être financé par des
institutions du sens famille déjà on a
un petit salaire voilà ici
moi j'ai 30 ans de carrière à et
metropcs 30 ans d'engagement jour et
nuit je gagne 700 euros nets et des
chefs de projets sont à 1300 et donc moi
je ferai aussi bien rencontrer le préfet
que de ramasser les poubelles on est
livrés puis on donne vraiment les
espaces aux artistes qui n'auraient
jamais de l'espace de travail dans les
institutions et qui fabrique de la
culture autrement plus proche des gens
et puis voilà qu'ils ont aussi le droit
aux outils à la qualité de l'accueil à
la qualité des techniciens
c'est pas parce que c'est pas des choses
prévisibles ou comment dire non
marchandes que ça pas le droit d'exister
destiné à la base au génie civil cyril
rencontre des pochoiristes lors de
concerts et change de vocation
dans la lignée de blek le rat il réalise
des motifs en adéquation avec les lieux
le pochoir c'est d'abord un côté
pratique de le dupliquer de le refaire
plusieurs fois parce que d'abord c'est
un fait a été fait pour des messages
politiques
donc voilà pour que ce soit clair et les
mettre sur les murs dans la rue et
ensuite c'était utiliser un peu plus
assez récemment je pense que ça pas
quinze ans que le cauchemar qui est plus
d'une façon esthétique comme nous on
travaille
voilà les maîtres crois qu'on a
découvert des choses qu'on aura jamais
découvert si mes trois prix existait pas
et voilà ça a permis
j'ai beaucoup d'amis duc autour de moi
qui sont musiciens pratiquement tous mes
amis en flex originaire de bourg sont
devenus musiciens ou artistes peintres
ou dans la vidéo est vraiment quasiment
tout seul
je n'ai pas tenté
ce qui concerne la musique la musique
rock un moment donné on a eu la
possibilité de tourner et quasiment en
permanence comment tu passes du stade de
comment tu veux rodez un groupe s'il n'y
a pas d'endroit sur lesquels tu
t'habitues est en public à envoyer ta
sauce a aujourd'hui il ya les zénith il
ya des trucs comme ça face à
l'intolérance au bruit des riverains
dans les villes et metropcs est un lieu
atypique un des derniers bastions pour
la création
nous on avance plus on avance et voilà
on se retourne 15 on se retrouve
quasiment comme comme il ya trente ans
quoi la société n'a pas basiquement
changé au contraire
fouquet s'est durci je pense qu'il ya
besoin à nouveau maintenant qu'ils
appellent leur des choses en main parce
que si le public s'auto-organisent pas
et je n'ai pas de faire que les concerts
ressemble à ce qu'il a envie que soit
ils vont se retrouver dans des halls de
consommation comme ça se passe de plus
en plus patent chose qui est assez
hallucinant c'est de voir que dans la
plupart des grandes villes maintenant
tout pouvoir
on va tirer comme de création culturelle
et de l'espace de consommation
culturelle
il est au privé
c'est une vraie plateforme passé à
laboratoire buzz et c'est comme ça je le
vois quoi on n'est pas dans une salle de
spectacle tout ça dans un brassage
depuis puis depuis longtemps
parmi les fidèles genlis un des anciens
est verrouillé noire haute de 28.4 ali
peut-être les 30 ans des maitres up avec
un nouveau projet la toile
c'est un grand lloris il faut le gérer
il faut que les jeunes ici ils
s'investissent et qu'ils se bougent le
cul aussi
et qu'ils se fassent à continuité de ce
lieu quoi donc se retrouver au peuple au
lieu il s'arrête tout d'un coup parce
qu'il ya pu y a plus les et metropcs
original originel qui sont encore là
quoique pour toute chose il faut des
successeurs pour continuer la lutte
la relève est assurée aujourd'hui la
moitié des permanents à moins de 35 ans
et adopte les mêmes valeurs qu aimer
trope anticonformiste autogestion
autodérision caméra à la caméra j'ai mes
propres est métro vous aimez vous
mettront pas peu beaucoup passionnément
à la folie pas du tout alors mira elle
peut répondre à lui pas du tout pas du
tout il ya bien encore un territoire
plus passionnant le plus passionnant où
il ya des possibles il ya des faiseurs
de monde c'est pas les politiques des
faiseurs de monde c'est des artistes
tombé par terre dans ta gueule
est tombé
trois quarts que laisse tomber après
rama laisse tomber flatteur à quoi me
laisse tomber laisse tomber
le laisse tomber
de tomber
et les sondés à l'est où les laisse
tomber
ouais tomber
et